des plaques arraché au début de la rue
blayac et de la rue victor hugo déposé
devant les grilles de la préfecture
avant d'être brûlée sur la savane victor
hugo l écrivain qui a fait l'objet d'une
pétition il y a trois ans il lui est
reproché des propos colonialiste
je suis tombé sur un article du magazine
afrique mag sur internet et je n'y
croyais pas ça m'a choqué et j'ai
cherché à vérifier si c'était vrai et
j'ai trouvé de nombreuses autres ces
antiques des personnes qui dénoncent l
érudit brénac dont le nom exact et
chants de courbes on ôte de blayac a été
gouverneur des îles d'amérique à trois
reprises
il est aussi rédacteur du code noir la
raison pour laquelle le nom est toujours
présent n'est pas le fruit d'une
décision de gouverneur du préfet ou de
l'état français c'est une décision
d'aimé césaire et de son conseil
municipal
parce que c'était le premier urbanistes
de la vie qu'on ne peut pas le nier pour
préparer face et qu'il fallait laisser
une trace mais justement en multipliant
les noms de révolutionnaire et les noms
d'humaniste les noms de ceux qui se sont
battus pour l'émancipation des droits
humains dans le monde de montrer que
cette attaque une trace c'était plus
petit que finalement le boulevard du
vietnam héroïque plus petit que l'avenue
maurice bishop moins important
malheureusement ce qui nous ce qui nous
explose un peu au visage d'un humain
c'est que cela a été conçu comme ça mais
cela ne nous a pas été transmis une
autre lecture
elle concerne également la pente du
tricentenaire un bâti mis en lumière
l'an dernier dans le cadre des 350 ans
de la naissance de la ville ce que c'est
en fait ce qu'il prend un lieu qui était
un lieu coloniale et l'on fait un outil
la décolonisation et que
fondamentalement la fonction la
symbolique le sens du lieu change de
sens c'est ça du colonisé d colisée
c'est prendre quelque chose et en
changer le sens ce qui s'est passé que
la porte la portée de la symbolique la
plus forte du dieu puisque la
productrice horner a été faite en 1935
pour célébrer les trois cents ans de la
colonisation de la martinique est là
une boulette de nos bus qui si en
faisant d'abord cette espèce de de
rognage à l'intérieur du lieu
il rachète la fonction une vision d'aimé
césaire inconnu jusqu alors qui
s'inscrit dans la réappropriation des
symboles un travail précurseur